al étage on a à peu près une surface de
60 m² donc avec deux chambres pour les
enfants gaylord s'y voit déjà sa maison
fera 150 mètres carrés
les enfants seront donc à l étage le
salon la cuisine et la suite parentale
seront au rez-de-chaussée une maison
constituée de sept containers j'ai pris
ma calculatrice pendant de nombreuses
heures de nombreux jours pour arriver
avec un projet estimé aux alentours donc
avec livraison conteneurs comprise
viabilisation du terrain compris les
terrassements compris aux alentours de
80 mille euros avec maison fini
si le coup est faible c'est parce que le
couple mise sur l'auto construction
certes les copains seront là pour les
coups de main mais pour le reste ils se
débrouilleront isolation étanchéité des
coupes de l'acier pour passer d'une
pièce à l'autre
aménagement des cloisons des fenêtres
ils feront tout un défi car ils ne sont
pas du métier gaylord et professeur
d'arts appliqués et son épouse travaille
dans la communication les containers ont
été livrées il ya quinze jours leur
coude 19000 euros livraison comprise ils
viennent du havre et de rotterdam et
certains ont fait le tour du monde c'est
d'être à ce qu'on a trouvé donc
certaines inscrits l'écriture asiatiques
peut-être des prises de mesure des
comptages donc ne sais pas si le
conteneur a pu être utilisée comme
peut-être zones de stockage pour une
entreprise ou simplement en tant que
boîte pour transporter des matières
premières à travers le monde
donc c'est un petit peu la découverte on
n'a pas encore fait l'inventaire de
toutes les inscriptions qui peut ya voir
où on va dire de toutes les plaques
nominatives qui peuvent être aussi des
petits éléments de décoration à venir
sans n'a pas encore fait le compte donc
ils ont beaucoup voyagé
aucune difficulté particulière pour
avoir le permis de construire car d'ici
18 mois
la maison se fondra dans le paysage avec
un bardage bois
seule condition pour que ce projet
singulier voit le jour